hola o bienvenidos a migrantes el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo lo saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
centroamérica es paso obligado para
quienes buscan migrar vía terrestre
hacia eeuu y contener el éxodo es una
tarea que desafía a las autoridades de
los países de tránsito cuando los pasos
oficiales no son la opción para los
migrantes las fronteras porosas de la
región sirven de vía para los que buscan
llegar al norte con el alivio de las
restricciones por el kobe 19 el flujo
migratorio en masa parece reactivarse
guatemala se prepara para una posible
nueva caravana migratoria que saldría de
honduras antes de que finalice julio una
movilización a la que se sumarían
haitianos y cubanos un equipo de france
24 viajó hasta la frontera sur de
honduras en los límites con nicaragua
para registrar el avance del tránsito
por la región el informe es de kenia
torres y addison umanzor
poco a poco van llegando los primeros
migrantes por este punto fronterizo
ingresan diariamente unos 400 de ellos
su destino final es estados unidos en
busca de una vida mejor
este es otro de los llamados puntos
ciegos estamos a unos metros de la
frontera honduras nicaragua y sigue el
éxodo de inmigrantes
hola de dónde eres agua y no veremos
robar vamos a pasar el país emigrando de
cuba que no sirve la política hombre
castrismo a 20 kilómetros este
campamento organizado por las
autoridades hondureñas ofrece el primer
descanso a unos 60 migrantes haitianos
en la travesía del darién una selva
densa entre colombia y panamá
recuerda uno de los peores momentos del
periplo después caminamos como mi pierna
está enferma se camina mucho cuando les
useres panamá
tiene un problema antes en panamá
también tener violación mucha gente se
vio ahora en panamá si es tener la gente
se murió mucha gente se murió cada vez
son más niños los que vienen en estas
caravanas aquí recibirán ayuda
humanitaria que hemos estado apoyando
más que todo a los núcleos familiares
porque pasan bastante niños algunos
vienen heridos la ayuda gubernamental se
extiende al transporte para llegar a la
capital tegucigalpa donde recuperan su
pasaporte y eso sin pagar los 190
dólares para el salvoconducto que en
teoría necesitan para atravesar el país
todo lo camino en todos los países donde
pasaron la entera mira no quitaron
dinero donde un icono sonó a un trato
perfecto fue aquí
aquí en honduras pese a que los
migrantes no cumplen con medidas
sanitaria ni los requisitos migratorios
legales las autoridades no los detienen
pero después de cinco días deben
abandonar el país un acuerdo tácito que
conviene a ambas
en ese periplo por centroamérica hacia
el norte los haitianos corresponden al
45 por ciento de los migrantes que pasan
por honduras según el instituto nacional
de migración nuestra enviada especial a
la frontera entre nicaragua y honduras
kenia torres encontró a ians un y un
haitiano que sueña con la reunificación
familiar en eeuu
veamos el informe tras una larga
travesía desde chile hasta panamá costa
rica y nicaragua
yanzón y por fin pisa suelo hondureño un
poco de alimento y un descanso es lo
mejor que le ha pasado en los últimos
días
mi país tiene una crisis política por
eso yo monta en el ciudad
y viviendo una ciudad muy tranquilo por
eso yo salí de haití para este otro país
tras ahorrar unos dólares productos de
trabajos temporales suní partió hace un
mes con dos amigos pero les perdió en la
travesía pensó encontrarlos en esta
iglesia convertida en un albergue
temporal pero no hay rostros conocidos
solo migrantes de venezuela república
del congo y angola
es momento de seguir adelante solo pero
alentado con la idea de reunificarse con
su familia a que yo me vaya a méxico
para la de mexico para la pala viaje a
otro país estado viniendo hasta la
encontrar mi familia un poco de ropa
limpia un kit de primeros auxilios son
necesarios para seguir su periplo lo que
buscamos es que cuando ella no puedan
continuar porque a veces les agarran la
noche todo le damos esperar es donde
puedan dormir donde se puedan bañar
donde puedan alimentarse verdad la
capital tegucigalpa es su próxima parada
pero aquí enfrenta un nuevo problema la
falta de dinero
gracias a varias manos solidarias suní
logró juntar 35 dólares y comprar su
ticket para intentar llegar en autobús a
la frontera con guatemala
notable
mientras el viaje de los migrantes
avanza por los países de centroamérica
el gobierno de guatemala le pide al
hondureño trabajar para detener un
eventual éxodo masivo hacia eeuu la
última caravana de emigrantes con al
menos 9.000 personas partió el pasado
enero de honduras y fue disuelta por las
fuerzas de seguridad guatemaltecas hasta
aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes efe 24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]